we're getting close to the end of our
top 30 story lines for 2019 and one of
the top teams from 2018 has real
questions about whether or not they can
get back there in the new season and
that would be the Los Angeles Rams NFC
champions almost almost won the Super
Bowl I mean really you can say almost
even though it was 13 to 3 I keep going
back to that throw and RAM fans you know
where I'm going with this when Jared
Goff failing to see Brandon cooks wide
open at a time the Patriots led the
Super Bowl three to nothing he didn't
see him in time and when he finally saw
him he did not deliver a crisp and
accurate football and allowed Jason
McCourty to get over and break up the
play and that kept the game in the hands
of the New England Patriots will the
Rams be able to recover from that
devastating defeat we've seen Sean
McVeigh talk about how he believes he
didn't prepare for the game the right
way and hovering over all of this
whether or not McVeigh will improve
whether or not golf can improve is Todd
Girly's health we'll Todd Gurley ever be
the guy that he once was I think right
now the jury is out at best I think you
can also argue that he's not going to be
the guy that he was because that knee
problem where there's reportedly an
arthritic condition it's knocked him out
for all of the offseason program and I
think it reduces him to something with
less than a workhorse tailback so they
may get some good reps out of him but
not nearly enough for him to be the guy
that he was back in 2017 when he was the
NFL's Offensive Player of the Year so if
you take Gurley out of the equation if
he's not as effective as he was that's
gonna put more pressure on golf in the
passing game and then there's the bigger
picture question of whether or not the
NFL has caught up with Shaun McVeigh's
offense I mean look at what the Patriots
did they held him to three points in the
Super Bowl that becomes as we often say
the blueprint for other teams to try to
do the same thing once they crack the
code on what the Rams are doing it puts
the onus on McVeigh to take his system
to the next level to counter the things
the defenses are doing to try to defy
what the Rams want to do and it all
comes back to having the players who can
pull it off can Jared Goff take this
offense to the next level if Sean
McVeigh can indeed come up with some new
wrinkles that will get ahead of whatever
it is the Patriots did to shut the Rams
down in Super Bowl 53 so that's one of
stories because the ramps have emerged
as indeed one of the elite teams in the
National Football League they've got the
Seahawks and 49ers to contend with in
their own division who knows what the
Cardinals are going to do there are
other great teams in the NFC it could be
a very tall order for the Rams to get
back to the Super Bowl for a second
straight year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports